service kommt zu einem neuen video heute
wieder mit max deutsche und ihr kennt
alle die situation eher liegt zu hause
im bett macht vielleicht gerade auf oder
schlaf gerade ein und stellt euch die
frage war ich im jahr 2017 eigentlich
brav oder nicht oder wie pervers aber
leute macht euch keine sorgen denn wir
haben einen kreis gefunden was genau das
beantwortet und zwar indem man auf text
antwortet man kriegt war sie nachrichten
vorgelegt hat ein gewisser
antwortmöglichkeiten die man geben kann
und anhand der antwortmöglichkeiten sagt
einem was sieht in dem fall obmann
pervers oder brother ist sein wird jetzt
kommt die erste nachricht leute kommt
natürlich von keinem anderen als
verkünden
drei uhr morgens aber drei uhr morgens
schreibt euch faktor sollte die nicht
wissen was faktor ist fakt steht für
sowas wieso diese in zypern können diese
so fotos posten und elisabeth
unterschreiben und halt möglich felix
okay was antworten wieder drauf punkt
antworten you how to destroy the morning
the [ __ ] to sleep also gerne absolut auf
gar keinen fall das dumm
ich bin nicht wahr uab schreibt er in
dem fall das steht für bist du gerade
noch wach und mir fehlt eigentlich die
antwortmöglichkeit so lasst uns starten
ich weiß nicht also ich würde am ersten
noch neuland worten ich habe es auch
beantworten ok blanc ist unsere erste
antwort alles klar weiter gehts dann
bekommen wir jetzt eine nachricht von
namen leute also von unserer mutter die
schreibt wann wirst du heute nach zu
hause sein und die einfach möglichkeiten
sind später spielten zum 10 waren immer
ich bock hab
und das heißt einfach mal ich bin gerade
einfach oben was ist los mit dir du
verletzt was würden wir antworten da
müssen kurz was erzählen dazu also ich
bin eigentlich immer so derjenige der
als allerletzter von der partie gehen
muss ja nicht komplett im arsch bin vom
training oder arbeiten sonst was muss
ich immer als letzter von einer party
and max dagegen
ich gehe heute aber alle hätten immer
jung ist sowieso schon mal ein video
drehen weil heute die hält weil du früh
verlierst
ich würde dann auf jeden fall später ich
würde niemals eigene mutter antworten so
waren band immer ich bock hab so nach
dem motto heute mal dafür auch unten
rechts ich würde sagen ich wünsche euch
dann schreibt uns jetzt unser
arbeitskollege und zwar um 10 uhr 14
morgens can you well before the drinks
und friday und dass irgendwas um geld zu
übertragen und die einfache
möglichkeiten sind ich habe mich auf
jeden fall schon bezahlt brauchst du es
jetzt bin dabei oder ich wechsele die
cash app das wahrscheinlich heißt es so
nach dem motto ich benutze den service
nicht mehr muss den anderen nehmen
sondern damit er das geld nicht bezahlen
oder sollte man sie ja ich wechsele
gerade ich schreibe dir wenn ich
gewechselt
in vier jahren ja ich würde auch nicht
ich glaube ich würde auch an end machen
soll und jetzt eine frau perfekt für uns
leute das eigene junge geschwister teil
schreibt mein gott wir haben vergessen
machen wir ein geschenk zu fiesen
abgesehen auf jeden fall nicht wieder
passiert antwortmöglichkeiten sind nein
du hast vergessen das geschenk zu
besorgen
oh mein gott panik immerhin stecken wie
beide der scheiße und ich habe für
niemanden geschenke
ich halte ich habe hier unten rechts in
der ecke bleibt man besser die nächste
nachricht kommt hier fünf faktoren von
abend von faktor 2.0 ist der nächsten
tag bei und der schreibt deutscher um
halb drei morgens aubergine fragezeichen
was jetzt an der stelle damit gemeint
das weiß ich jetzt meine antwort
möglichkeit wäre auf jeden fall fragst
du mich gerade ob das nur berlin
ich hasse dich teuflischer smiley wollen
neues handy wer bist du überlegst dir
weil du auf mir jetzt angelaufenen
mädchen wurde an das schreiben erst mal
welche motive würden über verwendet wie
er sich aber stell dir das mal vor dass
das ist da hab ich so eine sache die
nicht wirklich passiert oder das
passiert liebe hass oder das passiert so
war dann halt der aubergine fragezeichen
jahr aber für sich vorgezeichnet okay
was würde ich antworten ok angenommen
ich würde 40 fragezeichen kommen würde
ich natürlich sagen willst mich frage ob
das nun fertig würde glaube ich nicht so
sagen ich bin ein bisschen spaß macht
habe ich würde das dem titel von gap wir
wissen bis heute morgen war das ja wo
jetzt leute schreibt uns die coolste
person die bekennen kommst du heute nach
zu der party antwortmöglichkeiten sind
ja wer kommt noch nein
und da ist die besten snacks es ist ja
was würde ich sagen
safe ja ja ja die coolste person also
stelle vor ich habe einen machen und
jetzt sollte die letzte test
textnachricht von basti von unserem
besten freund unserer besten freundin
und zwar scheint der oder die schau wie
süß und bisschen irgendwo der angemalt
dass die fans mich gesagt nicht mit den
antwortmöglichkeiten ja das ist ein hund
okay wer hilft dann vier augen
herzlichen wollte ist dann ich bin
verdient und dann an neuen und safe oder
ja ja das ist okay und jetzt sollte die
auswertung wir sind nein
ich hab euch das muss auf jeden fall
unbedingt leute macht es auch mal die
kommentare was ihr dabei bekommen haben
bis er wieder voll da ist wissen wie
viel bekommen und so weihnachtsgeschenke
die bekommt kann ich an der stelle nicht
sagen bist du schon so weit heute max
natürlich und in der beschreibung
verdient hier kommt es zu einer neuen
folge von was das geht vom ein projekt
mit unitymedia zusammen dass ich
moderiere wo ich drin umlauf um mich
wieder bei mir genau wie man wie es
eigentlich also nicht abzuschrecken und
hier wird der wunderschönen fresser von
carl krafft da könnte man klar
abonnieren und schreit einfach mal jetzt
zu hause und macht wieder von chick
auftritte